So very quickly.
My name is Sai.
And what I'm going to do today is that I'm going to run you all do a very small
story,
uh,
not going to bore you all with the talk on disability,
accessibility and inclusivity and all lag because not many people are affected
except the disabled people segment.
So,
but I'll run you through a journey of my life and probably there'll be a few key
takeaways and that's something that we could be interested.
And so to begin with,
uh,
it all started in 1984 when a couple in south India fell in love.
They got married and then I happened,
uh,
and when it happened,
obviously I had this additional growth in spinal cord or the doctors did not
know how to operate and things got messed up and there you go.
I ended up with disability.
The fun part about that is that I never knew what being normal was.
So effectively for me to know what normal is,
isn't even there in my mindset.
But the aspect that I was born with a disability came in much later in life.
Uh,
I believe that there are new terms out here these days calling disabled people
as physically challenged or like,
you know,
uh,
differently.
Uh,
if you're calling a disabled person has physically challenged,
it's as if you're calling a single person romantically challenged.
It's actually not going to make any difference in that person's life whatsoever.
Uh,
some people also say disabilities a state of mind.
But imagine if I was in college and I'm looking at three floors and I have to
climb all the three floors and someone says,
hey,
disabilities,
just to state of mind,
you can still claim the three floors.
I'm basically hitting nowhere at the end of today.
So under these circumstances,
my life took a drastic turn and this is what I'm going to run you through y'all.
So in 1984,
when I was born with this disability,
uh,
it was very challenging for my father.
Uh,
my mom and dad didn't have much of a formal education.
so it became really difficult for them on how do they bring up a child like me.
Uh,
there was no terms like inclusivity,
accessibility back then.
And a lot of people believed that it was sheer bad Karma in previous life.
Uh,
that,
you know,
they got blessed with a child like me,
but my dad did something really interesting at that particular point of time.
Uh,
unable to take the pressure that comes with having a child with disability.
He decided that he will actually more of the state.
Uh,
he worked for Indian railways,
he applied for a transfer and we moved to Andhra Pradesh.
I says even more problematic because moving from Tamil Nadu to under this means
my mom right now as a language barrier and she's with the scared and nobody
knows how my life will turn out to be.
And uh,
it's,
it's all pretty messed up by enough,
uh,
toward all lists.
Uh,
I,
we also belong to a typical lower middle class family.
So effectively a while physical disabilities,
one challenge,
uh,
lack of finances is a completely different ballgame altogether.
So if I get a fever or if I go through something which would involve a medical
procedure,
not only start emotional torture,
but it is also going to be a financial challenge.
But across all these challenges.
Uh,
what kept me going was that I was not even aware of my disability because when
you're at four or six years old,
you just don't know that you are a disabled.
You just want to go there,
play,
have fun and all that.
But the one thing that transformed my life was my dad's thought that the only
way out of all the ills that are willing to come down to me because of my
disability was through education.
Uh,
he strongly believed that education was going to bring me out of the challenges
that I'm going to face.
And He tried to put me into schools when he put me into schools.
The problem was not that I had a disability,
the problem came from the parents of other children because they started to
believe that if they get studies along with me,
then they would mimic my habits are,
some of them went on to believe that some of the disability aspects that I have
were probably contagious and therefore their children will end up suffering.
So they would politely go and tell the principal and college administrators that
they don't want me in the class.
The college principal will call over my parents.
And like every year,
this used to be a routine.
So over eight years I had changed almost like seven to nine schools as a result
that I was never properly adapted to one place.
But the good part of it is like I had plenty of friends,
or at least I thought I knew people.
So eventually I moved on to 10th class and I promised my dad that,
you know,
that,
uh,
whatever happens,
in class 10th,
I will definitely get state first rank in the public entrance examination.
The fun part about that promise was that when the results came,
I got first,
but from the bottom basically egg pass who shall live with one mark,
uh,
I couldn't,
you know,
I basically scored 60% on my,
uh,
overall 10th class examine when the results came on the computer screen.
My Dad was shocked.
My mom started to cry,
my sister wanted to disown me and I was pretty much happy that I basically
passed.
Uh,
so after that when I told my dad that,
you know,
I wanted to pursue ITG and all,
he just looked at me and said,
you know,
just pass 12th class.
Barely.
That's,
that's enough for us.
Okay.
So I moved onto class 11th,
class 12th.
And uh,
the interesting aspect about those two years was that I,
for the very first time saw that my parents were disappointed in me.
Think of it like a lot of time for us Indians.
The motivation comes from two reasons.
One out of passion.
The other reason is our parents are disappointed in us.
It's like half the life for us goes off in proving to them that we are worth to
their child.
Okay.
So effectively my teachers were very happy after 10 ticklers deck,
this fellow human posture to the exam.
But my parents were disappointed.
For the very first time in life I felt that someone had expectations on me.
And unlike,
you know,
expectations,
creating pressure,
I actually felt good because I was not this like hopeless case,
hopeless cases or two times.
One,
you don't have warp on yourself.
Number two others don't have hope on you.
So effectively I was like very,
very happy that my parents were actually disappointed because they still had
hope on me.
But somehow when he sat down to study,
nothing went into head,
uh,
everyday to the college.
My mom would take me up on a cycle,
uh,
in front of the entire colony.
She would kind of like put me on the cycle and just drive me into college.
Then exactly at four o'clock she would be there then bring me up back to house.
And like she did that for exactly 750 times,
like two ears.
And even then when I read physics,
chemistry and nothing went into her head and I was cricket crazy.
Uh,
that was the irony of life,
right?
God kind of gives you passion for something,
but does it give you the talent for the same?
And that's where we want to plug the gap with effort.
So effectively as cricket crazy,
half the time I used to watch cricket matches,
ran one find days somewhere in 2001.
There was this particular moment where my dad was threatening me that,
you know,
I'll literally break the TV if you don't go and study right now.
And I told him,
Dad,
I promise you I will study,
uh,
let Rahul Dravid get out.
And a I will study for sure.
And that was a fateful day because rabid,
rabid,
not only batter that day,
but he bought it for three continuous days in that Kolkata test match.
And he never got to study for those three days.
But as he kept batting and batting and batting,
I realized one thing,
he,
he was a frustrating guy.
There's not an extremely talented guy.
He was not the such of the team,
but he was a guy who would never get out.
I mean,
when he gets out,
India is happy.
Just imagine that like when travel gets out,
like people cheer because action is going to come down next.
And if our own team is happy that is getting out okay,
imagine what the opposition would feel.
So effectively,
that particular moment I realized that maybe I might not be able to hang around
and be talented.
Like searching in my subjects,
but I'll hang around and study and get frustrated with physics and chemistry and
all those subjects like drive Edward.
So I started to study for the first time in life,
I kind of,
uh,
let's say rectify some of the subjects and then kind of picked up the logic in
mathematics.
And when the eventual results came,
uh,
I secure 942nd rank in the state,
in the state engineering entrance exam with state first in the physically
handicapped category.
Now when I secure the state first rank in the physically handicapped category,
my mom did marketing in the entire colony.
She was like,
you know,
my son got state first mice and what state first mice and God state first.
And like within about 15 minutes,
the entire colony new.
And I started to believe that every engineering college,
uh,
seat belongs to me because at the end of the day I had the reservation and they
thought,
okay,
now my life is almost going to be set.
So when we eventually went to counseling,
this was the funny part,
fueled,
watched this movie called,
uh,
inception where Christopher Nolan comes up with this concept called dream.
Within a dream.
Our government came up with this concept called the reservation within
reservation long back.
Okay.
And I was not aware of it.
So I will state first rank and physically handicapped category,
but it was state first,
physically handicapped.
Oh,
see there is,
the reservation was split back then based on the principles of not only
physically handicap,
but also physically handicapped and again,
on the cost basis.
So effectively the dream was to study whose money are university computer
science.
The system put me in to see Vat College,
Aaa Electrical Engineering Department.
That change in college,
uh,
introduced me to one great person because,
if you know where this colleges,
this is literally on site opportunities.
So everyday you have to travel literally like 60,
70 kilometers to even go to the college on the day.
I took the seat in this college and went back home.
I met the first villain of my life.
Now every bill,
every life has a villain.
And I finally met a villain of my life.
The villain of the life was the next door Auntie,
uh,
to my house.
The day I got back to the house.
Uh,
she was there waiting for me and she was living on,
uh,
did you take the seat?
And I was like,
yeah,
I took the seat.
And she was like,
you know,
which college?
And they said a CPAT and she was like,
very sick and they said it's there somewhere only in the city.
And she started to rag me.
Uh,
she was like,
you know,
how will you go?
Will you be able to climb the bus?
Would all these things work out for you?
Why are you kind of like troubling people?
Like there's and all that stuff in five minutes in this where there was no or
could no Facebook,
no Twitter,
this anti followed my life.
Okay.
And she kind of like kept an uptodate even off what are the events that are
happening.
So when she realized that my family was going to have a tough time with me
getting educated in an engineering college daily,
she put a status on Facebook,
her community say this family's going to suffer for the next 40 years.
Then 1500 is commented on it,
30 aunty share it.
And within no time in our colony we had become the family that was going to have
a rough ride all over.
Uh,
but those four years were rough.
somehow I managed to graduate.
Uh,
I was one of the advantages of being a disabled person is that there is so much
focus that you can put on only few events because there are only few events
which you can focus on.
Uh,
so effectively,
uh,
my mobility restriction in mobility allowed me to become a good reader.
Over a period of time,
I started to focus on my education.
My Dad had insisted that if at all I'm ever going to succeed in life,
it is going to be,
is going to be through education only.
And repeatedly that statement and advice kind of overtime molded me into a
person who strongly started to believe in my dad's view.
Uh,
I read this meme earlier today saying that when you repeat a lie enough number
of times I end up loudly enough,
people will start to believe it.
The same also holds could with truth.
When you repeat a truth enough number of times and say it loudly enough,
people will start to believe it.
And that's what I started to believe as well.
It started to believe that my education will kind of bring me out of all
troubles.
So I worked hard,
graduated again as the top of the university at CBT.
And,
uh,
in moment where I was getting placed,
I got placed with Infosys.
And finally when he got placed with Infosys,
Infosys asked me to move to my sore for training.
Now here was a guy who for almost like 2022 years,
I lived with his family.
Every activity of his life was taken care of by his parents.
So when they suddenly move to Infosys,
I experienced what freedom was like.
Uh,
I was happy that Infosys was not a living parents into campus.
If they did,
my parents would have stayed there as well.
Uh,
so finally I got hold of a wheelchair.
I saw,
I lived there for four months and everything was going great until one fine day.
I met the HR and uh,
there was this particular conversation I had with him and he said,
you know what side the postings have come out and you're going to get posted to
[inaudible].
Now that was a shocker for me because I was expecting posting in Hyderabad.
So effectively I told him,
sir,
I don't want posting to pony.
And then he said,
uh,
you know why?
So I said,
I have this disability and I can't take care of myself.
So you know what?
Ah,
why don't you give me a posting?
I had river.
Then he looked at me straight on the face and he said,
you know what,
if pony was Paris,
wouldn't you go?
And then I looked at him back and they said,
but tonight is not Paris.
So effectively a,
I much later realize that that's not how you talk to HR,
but you know,
when you're young and like blood is flowing in you.
I thought we would talk.
Uh,
then he looked back at me and he said,
you know,
in a 30 years long corporate career,
a one or two years here and there are,
should not matter,
so go a.
So I just couldn't take that,
that I had this huge ego back then believing that,
you know,
uh,
I was the top of my college and therefore I have a right to whatever posting
that I want.
Silly thoughts that go on in had seen an emotional moment in a very emotional
moment.
I typed an email,
which was a resignation email and I clicked,
could send the outlook and I had no idea back then off the consequences of it.
The shocking part was that the HR,
I actually accepted it and they go within four months of my comp,
uh,
getting into Infosys,
I was out of the job.
Now the biggest challenge was how do I tell this to my dad?
Because here I was just finished their training.
How do I go and tell my dad that?
You know what,
okay,
yeah.
Uh,
Hey da.
In that moment I needed ideas.
So I looked at the inspiration of our entire country,
which is [inaudible] now gone,
wrote a letter to his father.
Okay.
Saying,
you know,
this is what happened in life and Gandhi's father forgive him.
I thought the same approach will work for me also.
So I wrote a nice letter telling my dad that,
you know,
stuff happened.
So you know,
stuff must happen going forward.
So we have to do stuff in between.
Uh,
and when he read the letter,
he didn't cry.
He made the other person gray.
So effectively there was a big fight in house.
Dad was calling mom when dad's calls mom,
mom cries,
my mom cry,
sister cries.
When sister cries,
dad gets angry more.
This is called avalanche effect.
Basically know,
and this is going on crazy back in life.
And at one emotional moment I finally told my dad,
you know what?
I have figured this out.
Uh,
when I lived in Infosys,
I could survive there for four months because,
uh,
the wheelchair was accessible the very first time I used the word accessible in
life.
Uh,
literally took me 23 years to tell my dad that,
you know,
that place was accessible.
I survived there.
I think I will go abroad and study the movement.
I said that dad laughed.
And then he said,
dad,
I'm serious.
And then he got serious.
So I said,
I laughed.
Okay.
You know what?
I was just kidding around,
but that's just an idea.
So on one other finding,
I went to this kitchen where my mom was cooking and he said,
Ma,
do we think going abroad and studying would be a good idea?
And she got emotional and she was like,
you know,
would you leave me and go,
can you survive and all that.
Why is life like this?
I think Shani period is running for you and all that stuff.
So she was like,
let's go and meet an astrologer.
And I'm sorry,
where is that coming into picture right now?
So I really had no clue what to do back then.
Uh,
so it started with a step by step approach.
I told my dad that,
you know what,
uh,
I'll search for a new job but one condition,
let,
let me just write the GRE exam.
Let's just have as a that as a backup option and see.
So effectively my dad agreed.
I started to take the GRE exam and then once the GRE exam got cured,
uh,
and I scored really well on that and I went to my dad and said,
you know what?
A lot of my friends who went abroad are doing well.
It is not that I want to go,
it's just that I want to admit so that I can tell people it was my choice not to
go.
Because right now even I tell people that I did not go there thinking that who
even gave you that meat first to go and all that stuff.
Then he said,
okay.
I applied to about three universities.
So I applied to three universities in all Stanford,
Wisconsin,
Madison,
Texas a and m college station.
All the three universities give the admin back then.
And I was like shell shocked.
And because how the hell did they admit me?
I thought the Iq of the school for,
and we are almost like 10 points the day.
I got to admit.
Uh,
but when I saw the admit,
I was like really happy.
So I went to my dad and he said,
now the ultimate talk had to happen.
So I told him like,
we come this far,
can we make the leap going forward?
So when you look back,
when I look back at that moment,
I felt that that was a transitional point because large ideas when you tell
people it'll be extremely stupid are,
to give you a kind of a context to this,
this was back in the freshest party in our college.
There are two kinds of fridges party in our college.
One was the management freshers and the actual Frisch's party management
research is like where they give one sprite ones most are unsafe or how great
the colleges,
uh,
the actual Frechette is where the seniors invited all the juniors and there were
three rounds to that,
uh,
Fresher's party.
The first round was the introduction round.
The second round was the proposal round.
The third round was the dance rounder to make it into the dance around what we
had to do was give a very good introduction of ourselves.
And in the proposal around every guy had to propose to a girl with the rules and
she had to kind of accept it.
And only if she accepts,
we make it into the dance floor.
When the rules were announced,
me and my friend were shell shocked because we knew that we were a certified
item boys of the class.
And if we take a ozone,
get onstage and call female up,
she'll be like,
did this fellow just seriously think that you know,
I am the one for him on all that stuff.
So effectively,
uh,
as me and my friend sat down and wondered,
what the Hell should we do?
My friends started to laugh and I was like,
what happened?
And then he said idea.
And whenever friends his idea do not trust.
But at that point I was naive,
so effected,
looked at him and I asked him,
you know,
what's the idea?
Then he said,
uh,
you know what side,
go and propose to the most beautiful girl in the class.
And I was like,
you know,
are you crazy?
And he was like,
yeah,
trust me.
Go and propose to the most beautiful girl in the class.
And it's like,
what's the point of that will reject.
And then he said,
that's the point when you have to take a risk,
take a maximum risk.
Okay.
When you take a risk,
take a maximum risk.
If it works out,
that's it.
You can do festival.
But if it doesn't work out,
nobody even expected it to work out.
Okay?
So everybody will say that the girl was proud.
So the idea looked good.
Okay.
But I also had to take a rose and convinced the female out.
So I took her,
rose,
went to her and instead,
you know,
press a number sooner,
he yoga and all that stuff and they didn't work out.
But much later when I was sitting down with my dad,
I told him,
you know what,
that we are taking a risk.
But if it works,
great,
it doesn't work.
At least I'll become a lecturer.
So in here taking a risk,
let's take maximum risk.
Uh,
finally he said,
okay,
uh,
let's take this.
The moment he made the decision to support me,
right?
That was the point where I also thanked him and they said there was a point in
life where he was convincing me that I should get educated.
Here was a point in life where I was trying to convince him back saying I need
education for myself.
And then he said,
t care,
all this sentimental dialogues are good,
but figured out how we're going to take care of the finances.
But on that day,
he got convinced on,
he started to tell relatives and other people that,
you know,
we have decided to send us and abroad was their day madness began.
Uh,
because people were like,
you know,
uh,
are you crazy?
How would you be able to send your son abroad?
He cannot even claim a bus in the city.
How do you think he's going to live abroad?
And all that stuff.
My mom started to become emotionally very weak so I made her sat next to youtube
or watch videos shorter how us is accessible and you know,
much more friendly to people here,
there and you know,
try to do a lot of convincing but didn't work out.
That was also the point where a lot of people actually questioned me.
This started throwing Sanskrit conditions like you know,
a financial we burrito buggy.
Okay.
They started to say things like,
you know,
because your time is barrier.
Getting thoughts like this.
Some other people were like,
you know,
you had a wonderful job within forces.
Why could that are in trouble?
Your parents.
Some people even went to an extreme extent.
They were like,
you know,
your sister won't get married if you're doing all this crazy stuff.
And yet at that moment I was really,
really focused on the education and there was this big problem on how do we
generate the finances to study so if he can make crazy friend.
We started to roam around all the NGOs.
We kind of showed them our offer letter and we kind of said,
you know what?
I have this admit from Stanford and Wisconsin,
if you can go ahead and sponsor us,
uh,
at least,
you know,
for the first semester it would be really helpful.
We roamed around every NGO in the city or the end of the day.
The only one thing that we got was the petrol bill for the school team.
So effectively nothing worked out.
And then I was really depressed.
I was fighting or whom every day.
And then one fine day,
my friend called and he said the idea,
and I was like,
okay,
what is your idea?
And he said,
you know,
let's approach the media.
Uh,
so as if that was not enough,
we approached the media,
uh,
none of the,
we couldn't even get through the security gate.
So we stood outside the security guard for,
of the Hindu newspaper.
One fine day.
I,
we started standing outside from like 11 o'clock in the morning,
roughly around three o'clock.
One guy came out and,
uh,
he was,
as he came out,
we said,
sir,
I have an Admin at this particular university.
Uh,
so would you like to write an article about a us?
About me.
And then he was like,
you know,
which university did you get an add button?
And then I said,
you know,
I got to admit,
and Wisconsin and Stanford,
would you go ahead and write the article?
Then he said,
everybody gets an admit for MSD is just what's the big deal?
Then my friend had enough presence of mind researcher,
but these guys handicapped.
So this was like at that moment of big moment.
So we were like literally selling over a disability for an article.
And then that guy was shocked and he was like,
are you really disabled?
And I was like,
you know,
do you want me to walk and show right now?
And uh,
effectively he took an,
I took the interview and next day morning,
even as I was waking up,
there was a huge noise outside the house and inside the house vessels were
flying.
And I was like,
what the heck just happened?
So as woke up and was wondering what actually happened,
I looked at it.
My Dad gave me the newspaper,
The Hindu newspaper front page below portion.
There was this beautiful article called physically handicapped.
It mentally tough,
uh,
with my photograph in it.
Now,
that was not the problem.
The problem was the article could tell that my dad's salary and it said,
you know,
this person's salary is this much and therefore he is not able to kind of,
uh,
progress.
Therefore,
if any kind hearted soul is there,
please sponsor.
That was also not the problem.
The problem was old.
The villain rented this newspaper and uh,
effectively she asked my mother early in the morning is easier,
has been salary this much only,
and this was an ego hurt.
So effectively it was a huge fight going on in house and effectively all over
again our lunch effect.
Uh,
because my dad was like,
when did you even give this article to you?
And I have an idea what happens if you kind of like pitch to the media and stuff
like that.
Uh,
the TV remote to broke because I threw it on the floor in anger and all that
stuff.
Literally,
I started to feel guilty at one point.
I just wanted to get the hell out of the country.
Finally,
uh,
we started an entrepreneurial venture and we kind of made some money.
I generated some money to kind of a cover for the first semester expenses and,
uh,
started to go to the US and started pursuing my education abroad.
Uh,
in the first year at Wisconsin.
I took up this content because it was much lesser expensive and they offered me
the computer science course.
So effectively when it started my course on the very first day,
uh,
September 19th,
2007,
the day I landed in Chicago,
fantastic event happened.
Lehman brothers collapsed.
So the world went into recession.
So effectively [inaudible] that we didn't,
any period together happened so effectively.
I just didn't know how that will impact my life.
What happened was the dollar value went up by four piece and that means the fee
increased like crazy.
And on top of that,
uh,
I thought,
the US is what we see in a MTV or anything like that.
But I chose a place where it's news.
I thought I would choose that place because no is cool.
Uh,
then he realized,
first snow is cold.
Second problem was I taught,
you know,
when there is a lot of snow,
everybody faces difficulty to more around.
I by default face difficulty to more around.
So it did kind of get nullified much later.
I realized that everybody has a way around it.
I don't because when I use my manual wheelchair on the Snowfield area,
it's going to become literally crazy.
So in one fine day got caught up in snow,
I collapsed because of hypothermia.
And then when I woke up it was literally two days later in the hospital along
with the $15,000 bill and I was probably at the lowest point in my life.
Looking back,
I don't know what kind of kept me going then.
I would just say that at that particular point of time,
a sick and tired of life,
uh,
there was,
there is a point in life where no matter how hard you try,
everything falls apart at that moment.
Some people break forever,
some people become number,
they become like joker.
Okay.
They'll be like,
you know,
I want to do something chaotic.
And I just decided to continue my education at that particular point.
A over a period of time,
scholarship opportunities opened up.
I cracked through the scholarship and somehow graduated again top of the class
in Wisconsin,
Madison.
Now here was the interesting aspect when I went through all the struggle and I
could graduate top of the class,
I wanted to make a fantastic video showing people that,
you know,
uh,
any person can overcome the odds and they need not struggle so much and so much
of perception hurt should not have happened.
So I made this fantastic video in which I showed what are the facilities
available for people with disabilities in the US,
how education system there is different from the education system here.
How I showed,
I showed how accessibility is important and not reservation because in our
country reservation is provided for people with disabilities.
Reservation people with disabilities is like telling,
you know what,
uh,
we give you 3% reservation.
Uh,
which means that if there is a college and the college has tears,
uh,
and you're facing a challenge to climb those stairs,
well climb the stairs no matter what.
But if you get low marks,
I'll still kind of give you the,
I'd met,
it just does not make sense that you saw all the disability problem with
reservation.
You need to solve their disability problem with accessibility.
So I made a fantastic video explaining this and put it on Youtube.
Two people watched it.
Me,
my friend.
Okay.
My friend gave up half way.
So effectively I was like,
okay,
what the hell just happened?
And I tried to promote that video as much as possible and nothing worked out.
So on that fateful day I was a little low and when I was going back on,
my mother's birthday was coming up and then your mom's birthday was coming up.
I'd never missed celebrating her birthday at any time.
So this time we wanted to celebrate in a very big way.
And since it was just about to graduate,
I decided,
I saw this ad for skydiving.
So when me and my friend was there where they're standing next to each other,
my friend said idea.
And I was like,
okay,
what's your idea?
And he said,
you know,
you know what?
Get on top of the plane,
let's take the flight to 14,000 feet,
jump out of the flight and then we share mom happy birthday and turned off the
whole world.
So the idea looked good.
Uh,
in an emotional moment.
I paid okay on top of the flight.
When I wanted to jump,
I jumped at it because I paid,
uh,
primarily because if I hadn't jumped into the air and my daddy came to know it,
he would have pushed me.
He's like into a call for the flight back and said like jump all over again.
When I was in the mid air,
I had forgotten that it was my mom's birthday because I had to get down because
my mom's birthday would have been probably my day to day.
And also realize that normally when people skydive and they get land the land on
their feet and walk.
Whereas with me,
the legs were retired because I cannot learn.
And before learning and I had to bend down,
pull the legs upwards and land on me back.
And we had no idea how this was going to work out.
But that's what you do when your emotional,
stupid and younger.
And finally when we kind of took the risk,
came down and landed,
my friend had enough common sense to put an Indian flag in my hand and together
both of us creamer that this is for the cause of people with disabilities in
India.
That video went viral and people were like,
you know,
disability skydiver,
disable.
The guys carried out some people who are like,
you are my inspiration and all that.
There was this actual video where it talks sense and there was another video
which had no relation whatsoever with disability.
It was just a what a guy jumping from a plane and when he skydived people were
like,
you know,
they were caught.
Uh,
and the attention was there and that's when I actually understood that in India
the messaging needs to be a little different.
So that was the first point.
I started to think maybe we shouldn't preach people about people,
about accessibility.
We should probably try it from a different angle.
So I started with analyzing the root cause to try and find out why is there a
stigma associated with the word disability and that took me to religious
textbooks.
I,
the first book that I read was this Bhagavad Gita book where I read the word
called Karma.
People said,
you know you experienced disability because you did bad Karma in previous life.
And imagine like as a disabled person you are reading this.
This is Lord Krishna telling you on your face do last Gemma,
you'd reach tough.
This Jerma you are going to experience stuff that hurt.
But so I was,
as I was reading that book further,
I also started to read in that book died.
He said life is composed of five elements,
sky,
earth,
water,
fire,
air.
And he then adds only a person who has like a straight vertical spinal cord can
experience all these five elements to totality.
And it was like,
okay,
this is where I catch you because if that is what you want and that you tell
that only a person would complete straight spinal cord,
they can experience this.
Let me prove to you that that's not true.
So it came up with this elaborate plan that for sky,
we started with skydiving for earth.
I went to the Grand Canyon,
we kind of rented a helicopter,
uh,
went inside the Grand Canyon,
stayed there for a week.
And what happened because of that,
nothing,
just my manager got upset because I was not available for a week.
So effectively it was not hitting in any direction.
Then came water.
The water was the big challenge because I wanted to lose scuba diving.
But my friend advised me saying that,
you know what to what avenues,
what honeymoon couples do think big.
And then I asked him,
okay,
what do we mean think WIC?
Then he said like there is a place on earth where the Pacific Ocean and the
Atlantic Ocean intersect wanting to take a jump there.
And I was like,
you know,
there is a dream that is fantasy,
there is stupidity.
And then there is a zone behind that.
Why do you ever think I'll get into that zone?
Then he said,
no.
So let's try out.
And so I started to look out for people who would go,
who had done that probably previously.
Then I met this guy,
he was the first man to walk the North Pole and South Pole back in the 1980s
when I asked him over email,
why did you walk to North Pole and South Pole in the 1980s?
Is that too?
He said,
just because it's there.
Okay,
so effectively.
Then I realized there are crazy people on the planet.
Then they asked him,
you know,
uh,
don't you think that's a little stupid thing to do?
Then he wrote me an elaborate email.
He said,
you know,
outside when I first walk to South Pole and then came back to my native country,
England,
uh,
people,
the very first question that people ask me when I returned from Antarctica was
that,
was it cold Robert?
So effectively when he said,
people,
when you come from Antarctica and people ask,
was the continuant cold?
Then at that moment,
you know that people are inherently a little stupid.
Therefore you do need to bother about their opinions on the over email
exchanges.
I figured out that he was going on another expedition to Antarctica,
that particular ear.
So I asked him if I could join him in the same and he more than was glad he
asked me to fundraise for it.
Uh,
I went to a couple of companies and ask them are to support me and they said,
no,
this is not a venture that they'd be interested in.
So I looked at setting up my own venture.
Uh,
I started to train for g mat where wherein I could raise money to go ahead and
start going on this expedition.
It was almost like a six month planning.
Uh,
I lived in Argentina for almost like 20 days because the terrain on the Anders
is going to be similar to the terrain in Antarctica.
So effectively it was like training on the Anders.
And if you actually look at the Spec a while,
we train for 15 days on this,
uh,
and this range and then started on our expedition.
We took all these lovely pictures.
Then we went onto the expedition.
One of the classic mistakes that I did during training was that I was never
wearing hand gloves,
uh,
while I was holding my crutches.
But when I went to the Antarctic,
the first thing I had to do was wear handlers.
And then I realized the moment I wear those thick hand gloves,
I can never hold my crutches,
can never actually hold my crutches.
So the entire plan literally went to dogs.
At that moment I decided I will take revenge on the Britishers because we
carried them on our country for almost 200 years.
So I asked this British men,
can you carry me for a good two miles so that we can get into the continent?
Once we reached there,
he said,
okay,
take care.
Then we design sledges.
We got pulled for almost like five miles.
And on a Shaver,
our three day at the intersection of the Pacific and the Atlantic Ocean,
I decided I will take what is called as the polar plunge.
And we recorded that moment.
And finally on the or our three day only,
we kind,
it became the first Asian with a disability to step on to the Antarctic
continent.
And,
uh,
from there we kind of put up this pictures.
And by the time I returned to India,
this video started to go viral.
And people were like,
you know,
a handicapped,
they went on 30 calls,
so this element aren't calls.
So then people are like,
if that fellow goes to Antarctica,
you can at least go to school and large stuff.
And when people started to notice all lists,
uh,
meanwhile,
as if all this was not enough,
all the villain reentered life.
And she was like,
you know,
I always knew that you had the talent to,
to excel in life and that,
you know,
you could do well and achieve big things.
So why don't you guide my children also an inspire them and all that stuff.
That was the first point I realized in life that people's opinions can change
drastically.
They'll have one view of you today,
another view of you the next day.
Their opinions have no stability.
And,
uh,
another thing was as if,
all these good things,
we're not enough or of nowhere,
remember the video that I first put up,
which are two views,
uh,
that was picked up by American and he was launching his shows at the mayor of JT
and amount of research that went into that video kind of impressed him and he
said,
why don't you actually come over and have a talk on the show?
So this is like a classic Steve jobs quote where the dots got connected
backwards and a effectively from there on,
once I got into [inaudible],
j a ISB was also interested.
I started working with Isb and uh,
graduated from the school.
Uh,
I started to work for whom ministry,
uh,
wherein we kind of looked at generating jobs for people with disabilities where
a disability could actually be an advantage.
Uh,
but before we get there,
it was at this moment,
uh,
wherein I started to do the Sky Earth water thing.
I started to realize that a lot of people in our country are very,
very stigmatic about even expressing that they have a disability.
Uh,
we are in a city,
we are in Hyderabad.
Uh,
so effectively we talk of words like inclusivity,
accessibility or,
and all that.
But when you go 15 miles south of the city or any direction of the city,
if you go into a rural area,
people wouldn't even want to share that their child would have a discipline
disability as primarily because they are worried about how the life would
actually turn up to just reflect that,
uh,
reflecting on that and wondering,
you know,
how can I actually help those people?
Uh,
I was talking to my professor at Isb and he was like,
you know,
you did all these projects about sky earth,
water and all that stuff,
which is great.
Uh,
but it is only working on the awareness component.
He said,
every social problem has got three components in all one the awareness
component.
Another is the action component on third is the accountability component.
Uh,
things like this generate awareness that there is a problem or there,
there could be a solution out there.
It was a very interesting talk by my professor conversation with my professor
where he told me that Sy,
while a lot of people say that in all these activities are inspiring.
A ask yourself what inspiration is.
Inspiration is not about overcoming a challenge because if you are inspiring by
doing all these activities and overcoming the challenge,
you're also sending a soft message that there is going to be a problem and still
people have to overcome it.
It's almost like,
you know,
a mother will come to the college and if the mother sees me,
she tells her child,
you know what?
There is this good.
He,
he claimed the three floors,
he kind of did well in life.
So you also claim three floors.
You will also do life well in live and all that.
He told me that inspiration is not about overcoming.
The challenge to inspiration is about asking why the challenges there in the
first place and how can we remove that challenge once and for all.
She challenged me to think beyond the obvious and he said,
you know,
stop on the awareness aspect and think more on the action and accountability
angle.
And it is there that,
you know,
the major challenge came because when he started to work on the action items,
I wanted to generate jobs for people with disabilities.
Within that we looked at four segments.
One segment was the educated and employed segment,
which is what is a justice aura fair system,
educated,
educated people with disabilities.
Those people being employed.
Then there are an educated people with disabilities.
They are employed that sheer luck,
you won't find anyone up there.
Then there are educated people with disabilities,
but they are not employed.
This is the discrimination segment.
Finally,
finally came the an educated people with disabilities are not being employed.
There are,
God knows how many people exactly,
uh,
with disabilities in our country.
Believe it or not,
till 2010,
uh,
the government of India even refused to count the number of people with
disabilities because the major challenge when we filed our ta,
we came to know a as to why people with disabilities were not countered,
uh,
was uh,
then the census is conducted.
You have to go to a particular place and ask questions to the people.
And in remote villages,
interior villages and all you speak in local language.
So effectively when the census is conducted and you go to a particular house and
they have to ask that person,
you know,
do you have anyone with her mental disability or mental challenge at your house?
Effectively in Hindi you have to basically ask capture Girma [inaudible] right
there.
So effectively that gets very offensive.
So you just can't let go into [inaudible] and the 90 will bring up a points to
air.
And I say I done all that so effectively since there was no terminology for
people with mental disabilities,
the government decided us sweet shortcut,
they decided let's not come.
Okay.
So effectively it took a long time for the government to decide.
We are to frame a word for this then ask them right now the trending word is DVR
Unger.
So basically our divine Oregon right now,
uh,
because of which I can,
I don't know do what,
but the government has decided that right now we all will be called the Dave
young and now we are going to get countered and policies are going to be framing
it.
Fair enough.
But there was this huge group of people who are uneducated,
unemployed.
This is almost like three to 7% of the country and they are going to be left out
of the employment frame,
which means they can't contribute to GDP,
which means they're willing to be a burden on the family.
That owning a,
which means that there is going to be unrest,
which means that there is going to be frustration and effectively we,
it was my goal that instead of working in the discrimination segment,
we might want to work in the segment where people are uneducated and unemployed.
That took my focus to the hospitality industry where in I looked at jobs for
people with disabilities where disability could be an advantage.
The primary source of the idea came from the Mughal emperors wherein all the
servants of the queen of the Mughal emperor a that used to be blind.
All the spies or any others used to be deaf.
They used their disability in such a way that effectively in that job disability
would be a primary advantage.
Now,
not debating the morals or ethics of this,
but it got the job done.
We looked at certain jobs where noise could be a problem.
For instance,
if there is a traffic police and he's going to get affected by the traffic
noise,
we believe and he has to speak only through science,
then a person with a hearing disability would be an ideal fit.
In fact,
a person with hearing disability could be a job requirement in that scenario
because if you're constantly exposed to so much noise,
you get frustrated.
Then you get angry,
you get drunk,
then you go on beauty or wife.
Okay.
So effectively you could prevent this whole chain of events where in we'll look
at any job where noise was going to be a deterrent to the quality of the
performance.
The hearing impairment will actually act as a deterrent and we kind of made like
a fantastic report for the hospitality industry.
We also looked at the pharmaceutical industry.
We looked at a few jobs in the IT industry and we flipped the paradigm wherein
instead of asking corporates to generate jobs for people with disabilities,
we kind of looked at the people with disabilities and thought,
hey,
what jobs are they going to be in in which their disability in itself is going
to be actually an advantage.
We made a fantastic report.
We submitted it to the home ministry.
Uh,
I don't know what happened after that,
how many jobs we've got generated or how many summers has got a 10 on that
research report.
But effectively we started to make slow progress.
That took me my attention finally to the third component,
which is on the accountability angered.
A lot of times people believe that any issue related to disability should
actually be addressed by government.
But when I actually look at it,
it is not something that the government needs to address.
For instance,
you know,
if I go to my father and said,
dad,
you know,
this room and the stables location here is kind of hurting me.
He does not tell me.
Go on,
speak to their district collector.
He will come and change.
My Dad doesn't run an initiative at housing,
you know,
today we'll consider it as well.
Disability Day in our house are,
he doesn't run inclusivity initiatives.
He doesn't,
uh,
basically run it like a corporate.
The reason he took care of me was that he could,
he believed that I was part of the family.
It,
I wouldn't even call it laugh.
He believed that it was his responsibility.
Once I became his family member,
he believed that everything I face is going to be ending up as a responsibility
or accountability on him.
Took responsibility for my education.
He took accountability.
When the principals call it year after year,
year after year,
and said,
your son would not be an ideal fit at the school.
He moved me around at multiple schools.
He spoke and convinced multiple principals.
When my mom kind of like took me across the street every day,
all those two years,
they look at it as an initiative or an extra curricular activity or house.
They knew that this was a fundamental responsibility because they knew that I
was part of the family.
Somehow when I move into a corporate environment from a family,
that angle on this member is my family gets missing because we start to think,
hey,
he's different.
My life is different.
I have my own problems in life.
Let me sort that out.
The head HR is there for this.
Uh,
and I believe that is what we are trying to address through initiatives like
this because you would really want to understand that each person right from the
bottom of the ground to the top level CEO can play a huge role,
play a huge role.
It could be something as small as the height of this chair.
Uh,
when you're addressing a particular gathering that makes all the difference to
water,
a person is going to feel odd excel at the office on.
And when you start to show so much empathy,
then the person also feels responsible to contribute.
For instance,
remember back and 10th class really care what my performance in education is
going to be.
But when I realized that my parents were putting in so much effort and that they
were disappointed,
my perform with my performance.
And then I went out of the way to actually help and focus on study and finally
start to deliver.
And Dale came a point over a period of time where my own attitude,
abilities and talents transformed.
And it sat in front of my dad.
The man who first told me,
education is the way out.
There came a day where I told him that I need to go ahead and study abroad.
I don't care what your fears are.
This is what I need to do.
That's the transformation that happens through this transformation.
Uh,
there are going to be conflicts.
There are going to be villains,
there are going to be obedience.
Uh,
there are going to be failures.
There are going to be stupid moments,
there are going to be moments of guilt,
but you will realize that when you're fighting for what you are believing in and
when you're fighting for what you think is right for your life,
things might go wrong.
But even if they go wrong,
you will do course correction over a period of time and you will end up in a
place where in hopefully one day you can sit in a place,
a sit on the chair like me.
I am doing today and probably talk of what happened over 30 years of life in a
30 minute seminar.
It's pretty much what I actually wanted to convey over the session.
If you have any questions,
I'd be more than glad to take it.
Thank you.